economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela buena
noche bienvenida como ya lo estábamos
adelantando nuestros noticieros le
pregunto en qué consiste esta reforma
monetaria anunciada en cuba raúl muy
buenas noches pues mire desde el primero
de enero de 2021 como lo anunciábamos
cuba renuncia a su doble moneda hizo muy
complejo sistema de tipos de cambio para
que lo hagamos sencillo mire durante
casi tres décadas ha circulado dos
monedas en cuba' el peso convertibles o
el zeus y el peso cubano o el ceu p
ambos se canjean a varias tarifas
dependiendo de quien lo use pero lo más
común es que un peso convertible valga
lo mismo que el dólar y que para comprar
un dólar se necesiten 24 pesos cubanos
el nuevo sistema elimina ese peso
convertibles y fija un tipo de cambio
único de 24 cubanos por dólar
inicialmente se genera cierto
traumatismo raúl porque quienes tienen
pesos convertibles han venido tratando
de deshacerse de ellos y eso les quita
valor en el mercado informal aunque todo
será más sencillo de ahora en adelante
se espera que se genere un aumento de
precios de la canasta familiar pero
también de los salarios y de las
pensiones según ha prometido el gobierno
así es angeli acomodamos la información
porque comienzan los preparativos para
un eventual break city sin acuerdo las
conversaciones están en plena marcha y
terminan el domingo pero ya no les queda
ni meses ni días sino apenas horas a
estas alturas es más el pesimismo dentro
de este divorcio que como todos los
divorcios no es nada fácil escucharnos
tengo que decirles desde donde estoy que
parece muy pero muy probable que
tengamos que buscar una solución que
creo que sería maravillosa para que
reino unido pueda hacer exactamente lo
que quiera desde el primero de enero
no tengo ninguna duda que este país
puede separarse y salir en los términos
de la omct bueno y escuchando a boris
johnson porque no raúl nos planteamos de
una vez cómo sería una división abrupta
pues implicaría aranceles de lado y la
del canal de la mancha generando
sobrecostos para los consumidores
también en los negocios se enfrentarían
a más papeleo y controles de aduanas con
sus
respectivas filas interminables en los
pasos fronterizos pero lo que
probablemente más le dolerá al bloque
comunitario en especial a países como
francia será perder el acceso a aguas
británicas que es en donde sacan gran
parte de su pesca a esto se suma que los
ciudadanos británicos perderían su
derecho a vivir y trabajar en la unión
europea a menos que hoy ya estén
residiendo allí así de saniel ahí es que
en europa ya vieron el efecto de la
pandemia sobre los salarios si la
oficina de estadísticas concluyó que la
pérdida estimada de ingresos laborales
promedio en la unión europea del 52 por
ciento este año en comparación con los
salarios de 2019 en croacia grecia y
chipre están los que más han perdido
poder adquisitivo sobre todo entre
quienes ganan menos dinero entretanto en
letonia hungría y suiza ha sido más
afortunado si la pérdida de ingresos
promedio en estos países ha sido más
baja que en el resto de la región y el
congreso de eeuu intenta evitar un
cierre administrativo
de esta manera la historia amenaza con
repetirse raúl porque a finales de 2018
como usted lo recordará hubo un cierre
administrativo de más de un mes en este
país este viernes a la medianoche vencía
el plazo para aprobar una extensión de
fondos federales vencidos el miércoles
lo aprobó la cámara baja y hoy el senado
que por una semana apenas ahora tienen
hasta el 18 de diciembre para probar 1.4
billones de dólares en gastos hasta
septiembre de 2021 si no se aprueban
estos fondos podría haber un cierre
parcial administrativo que afectaría
desde algunas operaciones aeroportuarias
hasta parques nacionales y algunas
actividades del departamento de estado
así de daniela indicadores como cerraron
las bolsas esta semana wall street de
cerró mixto con disney disparado en más
del 13 por ciento después de anunciar
que tiene más de 137 millones de
suscriptores en su plataforma de
streaming en europa el pesimismo sobre
el break sin golpe o a las principales
bolsas y en américa latina brasil
completa seis semanas al alza
y para finalizar que nos trae como cifra
el día 50 mil 999 toneladas de aguacate
hass que exportó colombia en los
primeros 9 meses del año este país acaba
de crear mejor el colombia avocado board
que es un organismo con el que busca
promocionarse en eeuu es tan rico que es
el aguacate de daniela muchísimas
gracias como siempre por toda la
información ustedes también gracias
buena noche
i